Numpy also comes with bunch of
handy functions to generate arrays
filled with random values.
These functions are defined
in numpy's random module.
The random function
generates uniformly sampled
floating point values between 0 and
1, with 0 inclusive and 1 exclusive.
More formally,
we can say that it generates values in
the half open interval 0.0 and 1.0.
Let's go ahead and print this.
Here is the generated array with
five rows and four columns.
Note that we pass the array
shape as a tupple.
A slightly radiant of this function
is rand which randomly accepts
a sequence of numbers as arguments and
straight of the tuple.
It is otherwise equal valid.
Observe that, we directly pass
the values of the rows and
columns through the function and
did not define a tuple.
Here it is the area with same shape
as before five rows and four columns.
Numpy provides this to achieve
a greater compatibility
with the more established
math lab syntax.
We highly recommend using a more
consistent num pi function
that explicitly accepts a shape tuple.
Now both the function, rand and
random, sample, uniformly,
from the rain 0 and 1.
What if you wanted a sample
from a different distribution?
To sample, or normal distribution,
we can use the normal function.
Recall the normal function
from numpy dot random and
pass the shape of the array required.
Let's run this.
The core produced a 2 into 3 array
of random numbers with
a standard normal distribution.
That is 0 mean, and
unit standard deviation.
You can change the mean and
the standard deviation as well.
Let's see how to do that.
We change the mean to 50 and
standard deviation to 10.
Now, let's see the output.
Notice that the values
are centered around 50.
To generate integers,
we can use the randint function
in one of the several ways.
Passing to values 0 and
10 will not divide randint to generate
a single integer between the range 0 and
10.
We can also specify randint how many
integers we want between between 0 and
10 by specifying the size attribute and
giving it a value.
So, this statement
will give us a 1d array
of 5 integers between the range 0 and
10.
Going forward with that, we can pass
a tuple value to the attribute size,
which will create a 2d array with all
the values between the range 0 and 10.
Now, let's see the output.
These are the single random integers
between the range 0 and 10.
Next, we created a 1d
array with five values.
Note that,
we mentioned the number of values needed
in the one dimensional array
with the parameter size.
Passing a tuple to the size
parameter gave us the 2d values.
And also note that all the values
of the array are between 0 and 10.
Check out the random sampling
routines on the numpy website for
more distribution and usage radiations.
Find the link in the instructor's notes.